[Musique]
l'info intox ce soir avec anthony st
léger anthony bonsoir bonsoir à tous et
on va s'intéresser avec vos
l'afghanistan près de six mois après
l'arrivée des talibans au pouvoir des
internautes font état de destruction
massive de téléphone portable en lui des
internautes qui se base sur ces images
on va les découvrir ensemble regarder
des hommes qui pour certains sont en
uniforme et qui écrase sciemment avec
leurs pieds ou pouces d'un revers de
pied des centaines de téléphones
portables cette vidéo c'est une vidéo
youtube qui a été publié vous le voyez
le 15 janvier à dernier et qui a cumulé
plus de 30000 vu ces images elles sont
reprises dans diverses publications que
ce soit sur instagram twitter ou encore
facebook cumulant chaque fois facilement
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de vues
et pour certains internautes qui en plus
de les réveiller il les agrémente de
certaines légendes comme celui ci qui
assure que les téléphones portables sont
interdits en afghanistan et que
quiconque les utiliserai serait exposée
à de lourdes sanctions en l'occurrence
selon ce tweet aux condamnés à la peine
de mort alors pourquoi c'est fou eh bien
il se fait en deux étapes finalement
concernant l'image elle est authentique
on va revenir dessus mais ces téléphones
ils n'ont pas été détruits en
afghanistan mais au pakistan
retour donc sur cette vidéo virale un
détail attire l'attention c'est ce
drapeau que l'on voit ici sur l'uniforme
ça n'a rien à voir avec le drapeau
afghane afghan mais c'est le drapeau
pakistanais donc ça mais évidemment la
puce à l'oreille ensuite lorsque vous
cherchez sur youtube trois mots clés en
anglais que son pakistan destruction et
founds vous tombez sur une vidéo plus
longue que l'on va voir ici c'est la
troisième occurrence et quand vous
regarder dans le détail vous retombez
ici sur des images similaires alors je
dis bien similaire a pas identiques
d'hommes en uniforme qui détruisent des
téléphones portables on reconnaît si on
a un petit peu là et vous voyez dans le
fond de l'image le conteneur bleus que
l'on voyait tout à l'heure dans la vidéo
virale alors cet hymne à cette vidéo
elle porte pour légende se 7,7 des
descriptions on va dire une cérémonie de
destruction de bouteilles peut-on voir
saisies par la douane à karachi on va
voir pourquoi à bouteille parce que si
on pousse la recherche un petit peu plus
loin et bien on va taper les mêmes mots
clés que tout à l'heure en ourdou donc
l'une des langues officielles du
pakistan on tombe sur des vidéos
similaires par exemple ici sur facebook
on voit donc ses hommes en uniforme
toujours en train d'écraser et de
pousser ses téléphones portables etc la
presse en fait qui va nous permettre
d'en savoir un petit peu plus parce que
lorsqu'on se penche sur ce journal
pakistanais en anglais on en sait un
petit peu plus sur le contexte en fait
c'est une destruction qui a eu lieu le
29 décembre à karachi et avec les
téléphones portables il y avait bien des
bouteilles des bouteilles d'alcool mais
aussi de la drogue ou encore à des
cigarettes et elles ont été détruites
tout simplement parce qu'elles étaient
issues de la contrebande et c'est un
butin d'environ quand même 29 millions
d'euros comme m alors qu'en est il des
téléphones portables est ce qu'ils sont
interdits en afghanistan comme l'ont
affirmé certains internautes alors c'est
la deuxième étape effectivement de 7,1
fox non ils sont autorisés dans le pays
cela a été confirmé par des sources
locales aux observateurs de france 24
les talibans eux mêmes elle les utilise
alors c'est vrai qu'avant leur arrivée
au pouvoir en août dernier dans
certaines provinces qu'il contrôlait
il les avait interdit comme dans celle
de race ni dans le centre du pays c'est
ce que rapportait d'ailleurs en août
2020 déjà le journal local gandhara le
journal qui on voit dans son titre
évoque aussi l'interdiction de la
musique on va y revenir un petit peu
plus tard pour ce qui est des téléphones
portables il n'est pas rare toutefois
que ceux de journalistes ou de membres
des ong soient complètement détruit pour
le risque qu'il représente pour pouvoir
et une fois c'est vrai aux commandes du
pays les talibans aussi un peu fait le
ménage dans le téléphone de certains
leurs concitoyens à la recherche
d'éléments compromettants qui pouvait
établir des liens avec les occidentaux
notamment les américains mais aussi
qu'ils contenaient de la musique on y
revient à cette musique parce que
effectivement si elle n'est pas
religieuse elle est interdite dans le
pays encore récemment et bien des des
instruments ont été brûlés ou détruits
en public on le voit ici le cas de cet
instrument qui va être détruit vous le
voyez avec cette pierre l'exemple de ce
soir finalement il est assez simple il
nous montre une fois de plus qu'en
voulant surfer sur un contexte assez
réelle qu'elle arrivait des talibans et
avec elle aussi évidemment la mise en
place de loi est liberticide et bien à
défaut ctos décontextualisés ou donner
des messages erronés depuis leur arrivée
au pouvoir d'ailleurs les talibans ont
des victimes finalement de plusieurs un
fox je vous invite à consulter le site
des observateurs pour des observateurs
pour avoir plusieurs exemples merci
beaucoup anthony st léger puis on peut
retrouver votre chronique bien sûr sur
notre site internet
www.francebillet.com nous on se retrouve
dans quelques instants paris direct
continue après une courte pause rester
avec nous
[Musique]